So today we're going to finish up talking about Nozick.
Um,
and that will give you time to just spend your spring break reading roles,
which is,
I know,
I know what you will all do.
Um,
but I want to come back to something I mentioned briefly about Nozick and just
reiterate that he thinks that in order to have a convincing account of justice,
it really has to have three components.
One,
when he calls justice in acquisition to what he calls justice in transfer and
three what he refers to as the rectification of past injustices.
You need accounts of all of those things,
how people got to have what they have.
Okay,
what should govern transactions among them.
And then what should you do about past injustices?
And actually in what we've done already,
you,
you've got the main components of his account in front of you or in your notes
from last week because,
um,
his theory of justice in acquisition is a theory that's intended to respond to
the left critique of markets that I'm going to talk about shortly is theory of
justice in transfer is the parade.
Oh system.
And his theory of the rectification of past injustices is a discussion of
compensation that we had last time.
So
let's think first about this idea of justice in acquisition.
What he has in mind here is the left critique of markets.
What he has in mind is the garbage in garbage out phenomenon that the parade,
oh principle is a purely procedural principle that takes for granted some status
quo or we worked through this with the bag lady and Trump and all of that when
we did the parade [inaudible] system.
And he has actually an ingenious answer to this critique and he uses as its way
into it that well,
Chamberlain example,
anybody remember what Nozick says about wealth?
Chamberlain who was well Chamberlain,
it was well chamber.
Yeah,
he was the best basketball player in the world until Michael Jordan came along
right?
Until Larry Byrd came along.
Okay.
Well,
fortunately Nozick didn't have to adjudicate that one.
Okay.
Um,
and so Nozick says,
you know,
um,
chamber is making a contract with,
with the owner of a team just like professional players do,
but this,
this contract has a side agreement to it.
Um,
anyone to remember what the side agreement was.
What was the
agreement?
Anybody.
Yeah.
Over there
wasn't it?
That um,
will Chamberlain gets a quarter of every dollar that the team gets in ticket
sales.
Exactly right.
So,
so on nights when wealth Chamberlain is playing in a home game that the ticket
price goes up by a quarter and that quarter literally gets dropped into a box
and gets given to welt.
Okay.
And
apart from that,
his,
his um,
agreement,
it's like any other contract.
So obviously his agreement with the team owner is a typical,
um,
play his agreement and it's a Pareto superior transaction and there's no
question about that.
But the reason well
Chamberlain gets this quarter is because he's a charismatic figure and everybody
wants to see him.
What do you,
why do you think,
what is,
where does Nozick doing here?
What is the point of this?
What's he trying to show us?
Anyone want to,
it's not immediately obvious,
but it's,
it's quite brilliant.
So here's the point.
The point is over time,
well it's going to get a lot of money from these corridors cause he's the best
basketball player,
basketball player in the world.
And people want to see him,
there's going to get richer and richer and richer.
Yeah.
And so maybe let's say after five seasons of this,
he has millions of dollars and these corridors that have accumulated,
the people have been put in this quarter in the little box that goes to,
well
millions.
Why is this a good example?
Well knows what's what.
Yeah,
yeah.
But
yeah,
over that.
Yeah.
Well perhaps he's showing that even though this isn't an egalitarian
distribution of wealth,
it's a mutually agreed upon by all parties involved.
So it's okay.
Okay.
So paredo superior transactions,
just every time you put that quarter in that slot,
you make it voluntary choice and he makes a voluntary choice to come out and
play and maybe smile at you or something.
Uh,
and you both both kill you tell,
and he goes up.
So it's,
it's in that sense,
just like any other Paredo superior transaction.
So,
so why the whole rigamarole?
What,
what else?
What else follows from this example.
Think back.
Think back to the,
what is his real target here?
His real target is the left critique of markets,
which says if you start out with unjust initial conditions,
right?
If your system of justice in acquisition isn't Matt,
then it doesn't matter whether your transfers are voluntary.
So what what's he doing here?
What's the point of this example?
Thank you.
Anyone want to have a,
have a go at it?
Yeah.
That what we consider an unjust,
um,
yeah,
system.
Uh,
or,
and,
and just distribution of goods.
Therewell may actually result from what was originally adjust distribution.
Correct.
His bumper sticker is liberty upset patterns,
liberty upsets patterns.
This is his point.
He's saying,
look,
you know,
everybody gets so excited about the unjust initial conditions problem.
I'll tell you why.
I don't know what just initial conditions are,
have no idea.
I Robert Nozick,
you pick your an egalitarian fine.
Start with pure equality.
You believe in meritocracy,
fine.
Start with a meritocratic distribution.
You pick,
we,
I really don't care.
Okay,
let,
so let's,
for the sake of argument,
just say you're an egalitarian.
So you pick it,
gala equality,
strict equality,
everybody starts off with the same amount.
Now we're going to allow voluntary transactions.
You know what's going to happen.
You're going to get any quality because some people are going to put a quarter
in the slot to see,
well Chamberlain,
so this,
this staff about the big problem with markets is that the problem of starting
points,
the problem of initial condition,
it's just a red herring.
It's a sideshow.
It's bunk because in fact,
even if you,
you pick so your,
you're the egalitarian just for the sake of argument and you pick
this starting point that you are convinced is just,
and we allow markets to run.
It's going to be undone,
Josh,
by the voluntary choices of individuals.
And so I'm raw.
I Robert Nozick say to you,
we'll have a little sip syllogism.
If we have just initial conditions and voluntary transfers,
then the outcome must be considered just
that's nozicks little syllogism you have just initial conditions and voluntary
transfers.
Then the outcome must be just,
it's just a shell game to get all hung up on the initial conditions.
However,
because
you can pick them and we're still going to undo what you like.
So you,
the Egalitarian,
pick them people,
go to the basketball games and what do you know?
Five years later you have a lot of inequality.
And then the only way you can co you can fix it is coercion.
The only way you can fix it is taking some of that away from Chamberlain in the
form of taxes and giving it back to those people in the form of some sort of
transfer payment.
And that violates his freedom,
uses him to benefit them.
Nothing else.
So liberty upsets pattern.
What when he talks about a pattern,
conception of justice,
it's one way you specify some distribution,
whether it's strict equality,
whether it's,
you know,
Bentham's practical equality,
uh,
whether it's um,
some other distributed system,
whether you specify in advance what the outcome is he saying that's a pattern
conception.
And the problem with it,
if you could only maintain it over time with coercion,
whereas if you value freedom of the individual liberty,
remember Nozick is another one of our enlightenment theorists.
So let individual freedom individual rights is the highest good,
then you have to accept whatever voluntary transactions generate.
Yeah.
Starting from a system,
uh,
which you,
you have conceded is just so in a,
in a way he,
he turns the table on the left critic of markets by calling their bluff.
Right.
And it's a brilliant argument.
Now you could say,
wow,
this is a philosophy as example after all,
uh,
we never start from a system that is
why is universally accepted tippy just,
but I think he would make two points in response to that.
One is I'm showing you that even if you did,
you would still have this problem that over time it would get undone by the
voluntary transactions of individuals.
And secondly,
Nozick wrote this in 1974 but I think if he had lived while he did live long
enough,
he died about three years ago.
But if he had been writing this book,
um,
after the 19,
early 1990s,
it have had some very good real world examples of what he was talking about
following the collapse of the Soviet Union.
Because in a lot of East Europe and countries slot such as Czechoslovakia and
East Germany,
you know,
they had these huge state enterprises that they had decided to prioritize.
And what did they do?
Well they basically privatized them on an egalitarian basis.
They sat seemed fair.
So you know,
there would be these giant factories that had been previously stayed down and
everybody would get that little chit,
everybody would get their share of that factory.
It was very widespread in Czechoslovakia and Poland in particular,
but also in some of the other x communist countries.
And what happened?
Well,
you know,
some people they don't know what they were probably rolled cigarettes with them.
Some people put them onto the bed,
some people throw them away,
some people put them in shoe boxes,
some people started buying them up,
going around and buying up,
you know,
Pete pieces slip this factory that that'd be given out as a result of the
privatization and water,
you know,
five years later,
10 years later,
some of the people who had figured out this might be a good thing to do.
We're making an ass.
And you know at that people basically they didn't have anything.
So it's not a completely fanciful example.
Right.
And Nozick would say,
there you go,
you know what was decided as a fair distribution of these state assets at the
moment of privatization was accomplished,
but then markets were allowed to run and some people took risks and some people
are creative,
you know,
maybe some people spend all of their savings buying these things up so they
internalize some risks that might have turned out not to have any value and they
got the benefit.
And so there you go.
Five years later you have inequality,
liberty upsets,
patterns.
Now are we going to go and take the Megan's from the people who bought up those
chits and give it back to the people who wrote them,
smoke them and say as cigarettes or gave them away or lost them in order to
recreate
the pattern?
Nozick Says No.
Right?
And this is what he means by comparing what he calls historical principles or
procedural principles on the one hand with pat and principles or end state
principles on yeah,
the hand an end state principal.
Specify some results.
So I'm an state,
some condition,
some teleological outcome to use the jargon from last time.
Whereas a historical or a procedural principle specifies no pattern at all and
says whatever is generated by market transactions is Jost and this long,
you know,
200 year old critique of them based on the status quo.
We now see from the well Chamberlain example is just smoke.
What about that?
So powerful argument.
Anyone not like it?
We were all like it.
What's wrong with it?
That's what makes you uncomfortable.
Where can you give her the mic?
Huh?
Yeah.
Can you ride next?
Can you just give a yeah.
Okay.
Um,
I'd say that,
um,
the thing that's being distributed,
does it necessarily have to be money?
Like if you change the thing being distributed to,
I don't know,
education for example,
that like having equality,
there might be something that would affect outcomes more than kind of starting
from like a concrete equality.
Okay.
And why should we care about that?
Um,
well I guess it's,
it's kind of a way of changing the process as opposed to,
okay.
So that's,
that's fair enough.
So that's one thing somebody might not like about it.
Anything else anyone doesn't like about it?
Um,
well we'll achieve one's kind of like a self made.
Got It.
Talk Louder.
Um,
we'll try is kind of like a self made person B gets there because his basketball
towns,
but it kind of nor ignores the problem of like people who were born into
incredible wealth are important to incredible opportunity.
How does it ignore it?
Well I feel like they're in this situation with voting where you guys is that he
deserves what he gets and you shouldn't take it away from him.
But I don't know if you can argue that having someone be having been born into a
family that has a lot of money or being born somewhere where you can barely put
food on the table is necessarily someone's more deserving of having one or the
other.
So,
but,
but that's what he thinks she's answering,
right?
Cause he's say,
okay,
so you're worried that you know people,
some people are born with a lot of resources in,
some are born with nothing.
He's saying fix it just however you want.
So we'll,
you know,
start off by redistributing and we'll start off with pure equality.
If you're a allow markets to run,
it's still going to become an equal.
I would kind,
right.
That's his point.
So what don't you like about that?
Well,
I feel like there's a problem in the way that maybe the May,
it's that he leaves at the markets or to like truly free in some way and that
there's like really free transactions.
But I feel like there's not necessarily going to be ever,
but that's,
isn't that why he uses the,
well Chamberlain and it's only a quarter,
you know,
it's only a quarter for crying out loud,
and you didn't have to give it,
uh,
you know,
it's,
it's a trivial amount,
but there it is,
you know,
five years later he's the millionaire and you,
you're still working in a factory.
You're not comfortable with it.
No.
But you're not sure why.
Anybody else want to say what,
it's a very clever example.
It's,
it's an example of where the philosophers example really cuts to something
important.
Yeah.
What's wrong with it?
Well,
it seems like will Chamberlain is an exception because the bell Chamberlain's
and exception.
Why?
Because the poor will tend to stay poor and the ritual tend to stay rich.
And just because there's occasional disruption of the pattern doesn't mean the
pattern will be fluctuating like all over the place.
Okay.
So he's unusual,
but what about the,
okay,
let's grant your point.
But what about the example I just gave of the Poland,
the after 1989 you know,
everybody starts out equal and it just had some people see an opportunity here
and they get rich and other people down and they lose out.
Well,
Nozick is relegating like the principals to the very beginning.
He's saying you have to own,
you can only apply your principles at the beginning and he doesn't let you do
that.
Like it's a continuous thing.
I don't think he'd back down that quickly.
He'd say,
look,
the point of this example is I'm writing you define the beginning.
So you know,
after 1999 the Polish government defines the new beginning.
Everybody gets an equal share of state assets.
We did it,
you know,
we're creating private property for the first time.
Everybody's getting an equal share.
But five years later we have inequality.
Yes ma'am.
Do you use in particular the example with the shares of factories in the Soviet
Union?
I think that Nozick is perhaps making the false assumption that everyone is
going to have equal ability to make use of that fair distribution at the
beginning when in fact people who are poor are not going to be able to buy up
the other shares of the factories and it's going to exacerbate any inequality
that was already there.
Well,
I notice your point is well taken,
but notice I say Czechoslovakia and Poland because in Soviet Union what tended
to happen was,
um,
bureaucrats from the old system use this.
They're a special position in the bureaucracy and the intimate knowledge of what
was going on to,
to enrich themselves and grab a lot of these assets.
So,
uh,
I didn't want to go with that example,
but in,
in the east European country says there's a lot less of that.
And it was more of a sort of genuine new beginning.
But you still,
you look at a country like Poland,
then it rapidly became massively on equal.
Well,
that makes sense.
But I would assume that those small inequalities that existed in Poland at the
beginning of that redistribution ended up creating those massive inequality.
That's right.
It's just like one quarter at a time.
Right.
Okay.
But that,
that's knows point.
You don't need,
you know,
some massive injustice to be done at the beginning in order to get eugenic
qualities over time.
Um,
so,
you know,
that's his,
let's,
let's modify the wealth Chamberlain example a little bit.
Let's suppose what before I do that,
how many people think that the,
that the outcome and the,
well,
Chamberlain is just fine,
so he gets rich.
But you know,
people want him to get rich,
so,
okay.
How many think it's not fine?
Okay.
A few.
So let's now let's play with it a better and see if your opinion changes.
What else
he takes that?
What if,
let,
let's just imagine it's a,
it's a,
a single company town.
Okay.
It's a single company town.
All these people who go to these games basically work in the only factory in
town.
And let's just imagine that after five or eight years of this,
when he's getting close to retirement and he's not playing such good basketball
anymore,
anyway,
wealth says to himself,
you know what I'm gonna do,
I'm gonna buy the only factory in town and he buys the factory in which they
will work.
And so he now owns the factory Brido superior transaction,
voluntary transaction.
He uses these,
Megan's,
he's accumulated from all of their quarters to buy the factory.
But you know,
uh,
Time's a tough,
the,
this globalization Kyle on the factory is losing money and his,
his manager says to him,
you've got to massively cut your wages here.
And so he gets into it,
you know,
confrontation with the workers and uh,
uh,
they won't back down.
And He,
his company,
he thinks is not making as much money as it should.
And so he says,
well,
unless you take a 70% pay cut,
I'm moving this company to Mexico.
So they are in effect,
forced to take a 70% pay cut as a result of this transaction.
Now what about that?
What would Nozick say?
Well,
it knows it.
Say about that.
Wouldn't know Zach would be fine with it.
You any,
yeah,
that's,
that's the way the cookie crumbles,
right?
Losses.
Ms Lie where they fall.
It's a famous line from,
uh,
American judge called learn at hand there to,
you know,
that's what happened.
They chose to give him all of this money.
Maybe they didn't anticipate what he was going to do with it,
but you know,
that was then,
and this is now and uh,
he's entitled to do whatever he wants with his money.
Okay.
How many people think that changes this?
Yeah.
If,
if we,
if we doctor nozicks example in this way,
how many people think so sandy,
buddy think it changes anything.
Somebody who previously thought it was okay,
but now it's less.
Sure.
There's nobody.
Yeah.
Why?
Let's get there,
Mike.
Yeah,
yeah.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
So
real explanation.
I just think it's morally wrong,
um,
because it's kind of course some of the people,
to go by his money and everything.
So while before you just kind of earning money for his own happiness in his own
like utility,
I guess in this case he's using his money.
Um,
and team has had bad moral implications.
So that's why I'm slightly more uneasy with this outcome.
So it's,
it's why do you say he's doing what?
That he's taking advantage of the situation in some way?
I guess so.
Yeah.
Now notice,
well,
any anyone want to disagree with that?
Yeah,
well I think it changes the situation in a different way and that now we're
having coercion of a group of people to,
uh,
keep the pattern of wilt Chamberlain being in charge,
um,
intact.
So even though it does seem like at first glance,
like a,
you know,
mutually beneficial arrangement,
um,
it seems as though people are being coerced into doing something in order to
maintain a,
but where's the coercion?
Well,
they're being coerced into taking this pay cut,
even though it seems as though a really bad move for them.
So,
I mean,
they have no,
they have no choices.
So I guess they've been backed into this corner,
but while they have the choice of not being employed by well,
right.
I guess that's just,
you know,
we have this,
uh,
this essay question,
which some of you are probably working on,
you know,
Joan Robinson's line,
the worn thing worse than being exploited as not being exploited.
But,
um,
he's saying,
you know,
I,
I'm choosing to close down my factory and moving to Mexico.
Oh,
um,
I'm not coercing you.
I just don't want to run a factory.
We had a loss.
Most people wouldn't,
wouldn't allow the market to run indefinitely.
So for instance,
we have laws if you have,
if you have a hurricane and there's no water in as part of the country where
that's been hit by the hurricane and the local hardware store with bottled water
suddenly ramps up the price 1000%,
we call it price gouging.
It's an evil thing.
But you know,
he would say,
look,
did demand for water just went way up.
I have water.
Why should it be price gouging?
Yeah.
So that's the point of the,
of the outsourcing example,
right?
The,
the,
the point is at,
at some point,
most people are going to say,
no,
we can't just allow the market,
we have to pay,
pay attention to the context in which people are buying water right after
hurricane through no fault of their own and the price of water has skyrocketed.
And so we were going to have laws to punish people.
Paul who,
who um,
engage in price gouging.
Anyone
who,
thanks.
So we should have laws against price gouging.
Yeah.
Okay.
Now if we should have laws against price gouging and we have laws against the
sort of thing that,
well Chamberlain is in my modification of nozicks example
is proposing to do
anyone think we should have laws against price gouging but we shouldn't have
laws limiting what?
No.
Is that right?
That what he's threatening to do is like price gouging or,
so anybody think it's not like price gouging?
Why?
So what's the difference?
Yeah,
no,
I think I was thinking it's like mill's harm principle a little bit.
So maybe you could actually find before the price gouging and for wilt
Chamberlain a reason to allow a government to say that you're not allowed to do
it,
even though it seems perfectly fine as a market transaction.
So it's a w,
but what is the difference?
I'm saying they're similar because they both involve harming people.
They both involve harming people.
But the price gouging is worse somehow than what wealth is proposing to do.
Well,
I am not saying that it's necessarily worse.
I could be,
but I don't have a definite reason to say so.
Okay.
So I think nozicks point is going to be,
well,
you know,
anytime you're going to step in,
anytime the government is going to step in and say this cross some line,
uh,
for,
even though it's voluntary transactions,
they're not voluntary in any meaningful sense because people are in such
extremists.
Okay.
Um,
the,
um,
okay.
Price gouging situation is,
um,
an example,
but you're still gonna have to say,
well,
how do we know where to draw that line?
When,
when is it,
um,
when is it going to be the case that
the position we are putting people in and saying choose is so bad that uh,
the government steps in,
is it when they're about to die?
Uh,
or is it,
you know,
not quite that far,
but how,
where,
where are we going to decide what is the point at which we step in and start
making interpersonal judgments of utility?
That's why we really saying,
right.
We were saying,
um,
at some point we're going to step in,
the state's going to step in,
but um,
we don't have a very good account of at what point this,
if you say at no point is the going to step in,
then you're really back to saying,
you know,
in the,
in the example we talked about way back with the Edgeworth box that the bag lady
should die because she has nothing that Trump wants.
And so that's supper,
righto,
efficient result.
But if you,
if you want to say,
well,
at some point before that point,
the state should step in.
You need some account of what it is.
And,
um,
given that things happen and circumstances change,
just saying if the initial conditions with Justin,
the transactions were voluntary,
the outcome must be just isn't going to be satisfying in every instance because
the status quo changes changes that can be drift if you like utility drift in
the status quo that you might and different people will,
well thank the state should get involved at different points.
But there are very few people I think who are going to go all the way and say,
well the bag lady should just die.
Or all these people should lose their jobs.
Maybe that'll be a more difficult case for some of you then for others.
But
it doesn't seem very credible to say you're not gonna have any point at which we
are going to say the state should step in.
But now Nozick was one is say,
well even if I can see that,
that
we really want to keep it to a minimum
because the problem is we don't agree.
The problem about having any,
any patent or end state conception of what's allowable in society is we don't
agree.
We have deep pluralism of values in this society.
What some people think is right,
other people don't think it's right.
And why should the people who are in the majority get to impose their view on
everybody else?
Or indeed,
why should people are in a minority get to impose their view on anybody else?
Why should anybody get to impose their view on anybody else?
That's his plan.
And we saw in the last lecture that he made a distinction between redistribution
and compensation.
Remember he said that we would only get the minimal state as a result of
forcible inclusion of independence,
but if they could in principle be compensated,
making it legitimate,
we wouldn't get anything more because people don't agree.
So some people would say it's terrible for people to lose.
Their others would say,
oh,
well I should have thought about that when they were putting all those corridors
in the box that they giving him power.
So
if you cast your mind back to last week's,
uh,
last week's lecture on Wednesday,
we ended up saying,
well,
no zincs argument isn't as powerful as it looks because we could do more in the
name of compensation that he wants to do,
right?
We could,
we could allow,
um,
the creation of an employment insurance.
Um,
remember this,
the fear of odd being unemployed and all of that.
So he might agree about that,
but say,
you know,
it's still better.
It's still better to think in a compensatory idiom for one thing.
Yes,
you might get unemployment insurance that way,
but thank you for all the things a welfare state does.
It gives protection to the disabled.
It gives,
um,
you know,
civil rights guarantees.
These are all sorts of things that,
um,
what did it come about?
Um,
because not enough people would want them.
I know,
you know,
the disabled are minority.
The African Americans before the Civil Rights Act were a minority,
so they wouldn't be able to force everybody takes sect what they wanted.
So it wouldn't get done as,
as a result of the kind of mechanism that creates the minimal state.
There'd be a lot of things government currently does that wouldn't happen
and it's better to have compensation rather than redistribution because
compensation doesn't require us to agree about
a pattern.
It doesn't require us to agree on what kind of outcome is actually just the
whole idea of compensation is
making somebody whole,
you know,
if one of you walks up to the street and punches me in the face,
okay,
and I go to court and sue you.
The question is how,
what damage,
what damage did that angry student duty and Shapiro and how much should Shapiro
be compensated to port?
I'm on at least as high an indifference curve as he was before that.
Right?
That's the only question we don't have to ask.
The question,
should he have been where he was before?
Is the distribution of wealth in society that existed before Shapiro was punched
by the angry student?
Was that Josh,
we don't have to ask that question.
If we're going to do compensation,
we just say,
how do we make Shapiro Hall?
How does,
how does the person who harmed them make him whole,
how much money does he have to give him to make him whole?
That's only question we have to answer and Nozick wants to say
that it's,
it's a much easier thing to deal with precisely because in a society where
there's deep pluralism of values where we don't agree on watch,
just um,
it's a much more limited in inquiry into how do we compensate some particular
individual to undo
the particular harm that was done to them and make them whole.
We don't have to agree on what the just distribution of wealth and income in
this society is in order to answer that
question.
Right.
Is that a good argument?
That compensation is much less demanding metaphysically then redistribution
because compensation doesn't require us to agree on what is just,
it just requires us to figure out what,
you know,
what,
how much is owed to Shapiro to make him whole after this harm has,
yeah.
Is that right?
Is it a good argument?
Just because it's easy doesn't mean it's the right argument.
Just cause it's easy
doesn't mean it's the right argument.
But is it easy?
Will you said it was just metaphysically,
well,
let,
let's suppose we,
we could,
it's easy.
In one sense it's easy in a sense.
I mean it might be hard because I'm an say pain and suffering and you know,
I was humiliated and I got to get extra money for that,
you know,
and you know,
my,
my uh,
my girlfriend one look at me cause I got a black guy,
I should get extra money for that.
You know,
we argue about this in court.
So it might be hard in that sense,
but it's easier in the sense that we don't need to agree on,
you know,
what,
what my salary should be versus a banker salary versus,
you know,
we don't have to answer questions like that.
We just want to know the number.
We have to arrive at the number to undo the harm to make me whole.
Is that,
is that a bad argument?
Yeah,
well it completely forgets like the enlightenment idea that there might be a
right answer to anything.
And just by saying that it just dealing in compensation and not like actually,
um,
okay.
Redistribution and figuring out,
yeah,
that's a good point.
And I,
but I think now it's like what?
Say I'm not,
I'm not saying there should,
there's isn't a right answer.
I'm saying we don't agree on what the right answer is,
but I knows it comes saying one writing answers not to coerce people.
So given,
given that we have different values,
the answer is liberty.
Let everybody have their own value and not impose one person's value on others.
So I don't think he'd back down that quickly.
Say any other reason anyone might think this is
okay.
I think you're in the right direction,
but you haven't quite nailed it.
Yeah.
So I mean,
in terms of money,
maybe it's easier to think about compensation,
but when you're compensating people with goods or services,
you're really having to take those from somewhere else.
They don't,
they don't disappear out of nowhere.
So on some level you're already redistributing things when you're compensating.
So it is really just another form of redistribution.
But in another
another word,
I think that's a good argument.
But I think that's another one that I just want to leave you with.
I think,
and this this partly reflects with when Nozick was writing,
it was right.
He wrote this in 1974 and in 1974 the the,
there was a lot more political stability in the world in some ways.
Then there came to be subsequently of course it was unstable in the sense that
we were in the middle of the Cold War,
but,
but the Cold War provided a lot of stability within countries that would
subsequently become very unstable after the end of the Cold War.
And so you know,
this idea that while fixing one injustice is how many we can get our minds
around,
particularly if it means making people as well off as they were before.
Where is deciding what's Josh for the society as a whole isn't,
it's much,
much bigger problem and it is potentially much more politically explosive
because you know,
we're going to be s and Nozick says liberty upsets patterns.
We're going to be taking wealth from some people and giving it to other people
and that people were taking it from on aren't gonna like it.
Whereas this compensatory ADM is,
is backward looking.
It's focus and it's specific,
but I think when he didn't,
what he did and take account off is that the backward looking idiom runs into
the problem of where do we stop,
where do we stop?
After 1991,
there were people in Russia who has said all that property should be given back
to the czar's children.
After the transition in South Africa,
king Goodwill's whaling teeny,
the Zulu King,
he said,
wow,
all that land that was seized first,
first by the British from my ancestors and then under apartheid was,
was seized a,
again for the,
the,
uh,
forced removals and all that,
it should be given to me.
I'm the descendant.
And you already have to think about the Middle East
to say that this idea that a backward looking compensatory ADM is less
politically explosive,
then I redistributive ADM as a political matter isn't true because it all
depends how far you go back.
You know,
um,
the Palestinian side,
we'd go back to 1967 or then there's a debate about going back to 1948 and there
are many people who are there say we should go back to the old testament as to
what this,
where we should undo all the injustices that have piled up upon one another over
time.
So this idea that the compensatory idiom is less demanding,
then the redistributive idiom I think is politically naive and ultimately
philosophically not tenable because you're going to have to make a decision
about how far back to go.
Okay.
Before you decide that you have the benchmark for compensation,
you only have to look at the vaccine history of affirmative action,
which was,
you know,
read Randall Robinson's book that,
that deck,
the VEX history of affirmative action to see how difficult a backward looking
compensatory ADM turns out to be.
In practice and joy the midterm,
and we'll see you,
um,
three weeks from today.